it's great to welcome to the program
today Daniel Markovitz who's a professor
of law at the Yale Law School and also
author of the book the meritocracy trap
how America's foundational myth feeds
inequality dismantles the middle class
and devours the elite Daniel so great to
have you on today it's a real pleasure
to be here thank you for doing this so
maybe maybe just to start with let's
start with what what maybe is the top
line story that's often told which is
the great thing about America is that
it's a meritocracy everybody has a
chance at making it if they are whatever
enough committed enough if they want it
enough regardless of background or
economic status etc how can we evaluate
the truth or falsity of that sort of top
line story yeah great so what you've
done is you've identified what makes
meritocracy so attractive it seems like
it gives everybody a fair shot of
success if they just have the hard work
and talent and it seems that it produces
an elite that's really capable because
it's proved itself in competition and
for a while meritocracy worked that way
in its early years it broke up an old
hereditary aristocracy but then what
happened is that people who got to the
top through meritocracy themselves turn
out to have an almost unbounded taste
and talent for training their children
and so the elite today invests so much
more in educating as children than
anybody else can possibly afford to do
an education works which means that when
you measure young people based on their
academic accomplishments it's the kids
of rich parents who do best and
meritocracy then perpetuates itself and
creates a new kind of aristocracy just
based on degrees rather than breeding
and that sort of assumes that there is
at least some zero-sum nature to
elements of our society in the economy
right I mean if one wanted to play
devil's advocate they could say great
once someone threw their work achieves
they become good at training their kids
and their can say their did that and
that's fine as long as everybody else is
not disadvantaged as a result of that
then it would still be okay
right so I think there are two there are
two responses to that that's I think
that's a powerful point the first is
there's inevitably some zero-sum
competition so that education is a you
know rank good and the value of my
education depends on how much education
the person behind me in the job line has
but the other deeper point is that this
new elite has fundamentally
reconstructed the way our economy works
the way we deliver services the way we
make goods so that the new economy
privileges specifically the narrow set
of elite skills that fancy education zhh
give and D values all other skills so
that the rich today when they succeed
more nearly push everybody else down
then drag to draw everybody else up so
if we concede that certainly we we don't
have a full meritocracy I think before
we explore some of the specifics and
more detail it might be interesting to
consider what if what a true meritocracy
really be the ideal in and we can
approach that from a few different
perspectives but maybe just I'll start
with that question what what would be
good about an actually meritocratic
society and what might be not so good
yeah so from my perspective I want to be
clear a full meritocracy would not be
the ideal it would be more nearly a
nightmare um what would be good about it
though and it has some good things is
that it would undermine all sorts of
hierarchies and inequalities that are
morally awful hierarchies based on race
or caste or gender or sexual orientation
or ethnicity those are all despised by
meritocracy and one of the reasons why
meritocracy is so attractive is that it
works to undermine those on the other
hand what it would also do is it would
create a new hierarchy based on training
based on how much training your parents
could buy for you and it would produce
incredibly unequal outcomes and if
there's one lesson of the book that I
think is really important to drive home
it's that the idea that equality of
opportunity can make unequal outcomes
okay is a moral mistake and what we need
is more equality
outcomes in our world can you say more
about that because it might I mean that
we have even though my audience is
mostly on the left I think that there's
probably a range of opinions in terms of
the degree to which equality of
opportunity would be the goal versus
equality of outcome can you talk a
little bit more about because the
quality of outcome can mean a lot of
different things and and maybe as to
contextualize it one of the things that
seems immutable in humanity is that
there is rarely exact distribution in
any field or venture that mirrors the
makeup of society whether it's in terms
of gender race age whatever right so if
we start with that reality a quality of
outcome can sound pretty scary in some
ways yeah sure and it's also important
to say I'm not and I don't think
anybody's serious is in favor of
absolute equality of outcome you know
the way in which like pro crustose used
to chop people off if they were to long
for the Betty stuck them in that that's
a deeply dangerous notion but right now
we have so much inequality of outcome
that it's hard really to recognize how
extreme it is the richest 1% of
Americans today control a greater share
of the nation's income and wealth then
for example a comparable elite did in
ancient Rome during the era of Imperial
decadence so we have inequality of
outcome that is just extravagantly
skewed and when that happens elites
used whatever selection mechanism there
is to privilege their own kids and so
when you get sufficiently big inequality
of outcomes you can't have a quality of
opportunity just to give you a way of
thinking about that very quickly in our
country today if you take the difference
between what a typical 1% household
invests in educating its children and
what a typical middle-class household
invests so not a poor household but a
middle-class household and every year
you take that difference and you put it
in the S&P 500 to create an inheritance
that will go to the rich kids when their
parents die that would be well
north of 10 million dollars per child
and that produces a massive skew in who
gets ahead and it's driven by the
inequality of outcomes in the prior
generation and that's unjust has has
this been a change in the last 20 or 30
years and by that I mean a change in the
direction of less conspicuous spending
by the very rich let less about things
that immediately show wealth like what
you know watches or expensive cars or
whatever the case but a type of spending
on education and upbringing that maybe
has a more pervasive effect in
perpetuating inequality well I think two
things have happened and the underlying
driver of this is the rich have just
gotten so much richer so one thing
that's happened is the rich are actually
spending more on consumption and luxury
kinds of goods than they used to but
because there are notes now so many rich
people they don't stand out in the same
way there are whole enclaves there are
whole super structures built to serve as
rich consumption you know they're
increasingly someplace they have
separate airline terminals for the
richest passengers so you don't see them
but it's also the case as you say that
no part of consumption inequality has
grown faster than inequality in spending
on education when we think about so to
go back a little bit because I think
this might be an interesting area and oh
I should mention we've been speaking
with Daniel Markovitz we're gonna go to
a break on the TV radio and podcast
episode but the conversation will
continue in full on our YouTube channel
if we want to evaluate let's just pick
something right like representation of
women in the US Senate just because it's
a simple hundred and it just makes the
math sort of simple right women make up
just more than 50% of the population of
the country and they don't make up 50%
of the Senate I actually don't have the
exact number right now in front of me if
the Senate is 5% women I think you would
get a lot of people who say there's more
than mere chance going on it's likely
more than just women aren't interested
in being in the Senate but if it's 37
percent or maybe 41 percent at a certain
point we would be able to determine that
the variance is is maybe acceptable or
within some kind of tolerance how do we
evaluate something like that well I
think with respect to class and
education we are so far from that we're
more like the 5% case so here's a
striking fact at Harvard Princeton Yale
and Stanford there are more kids whose
parents are in the top 1% of the income
distribution than the bottom 60% so
that's the kind of skew we're looking at
at the same time it also matters how we
support these institutions so that
Princeton for example because it's taxed
as a tax-exempt organization doesn't pay
tax on its endowment income has alumni
who can deduct from taxes their
contributions and that amounts to an
implicit public subsidy of a hundred
thousand dollars a year per Princeton
student compared to public spending of
twelve thousand five hundred dollars a
year at the State University of New
Jersey at Rutgers and public spending of
about twenty-five hundred dollars a year
at Essex County Community College
so the Princeton kids get a public
subsidy that is 40 times as big as the
Community College kids up the road even
though there are more kids at Princeton
for the richest one percent one from the
bottom 60% so it's both that there's
this massive skew and then there's this
massive public subsidy the rest of
society is paying to the rich kids who
get the benefit of the skew yeah I mean
and and and that that makes a lot of
sense and that's a really good good
example I guess just in thinking about
if we want to a priority for me is to
figure out where the worst problems are
and to signal them where maybe we might
have the opportunity of making the
largest correction so to speak and in
thinking about that it just to give
another specific example like a hard and
fast example if we identify that the
percentage of doctors for example who
are black is dramatically lower in a
certain special called dermatologists
for example in the dermatology field
black folks make up I don't remember if
it's 17 percent of
the country's population but they make
up only 4% of Dermatologists as an
example how can we
empirically determine the causes for
that and determine where the causes may
be pernicious and where they may be the
result of other less less dangerous
factors yeah so you know for class one
way in which we can determine the causes
is by working through the actual
mechanisms whereby people get ahead look
at what percentage of professional
parents send their children to really
high quality preschools
and what percentage of middle class
parents or what percentage of working
class parents do and you see a massive
difference look at how much is spent on
high school kids
the typical public high school the
median public high school in America
spends between 12 and 15 thousand
dollars per pupil per year on educating
its students the Forbes top 20 private
schools spend about $75,000 per pupil
per year on educating their students and
unsurprisingly those schools send maybe
a third of their kids to the Ivy League
or to Stanford Chicago Duke now what
that is doing is it's showing you what
the mechanism is the mechanism is this
hugely disproportionate investment in
much more intensive education which
produces much better outcomes on
standardized tests and then the kids go
to the colleges that dominate the income
leagues when they graduate so in class
we can trace out the micro mechanisms
that are producing this skew which gives
us a pretty high degree of confidence
that it's run through a system of self
persuading elites which I think most of
us would object to yeah I one of the
things that's interesting about that is
when we think about equality of
opportunity versus equality of outcome I
think that at least in some cases what
is claimed to be an equality of
opportunity really is not in other words
rather than maybe before I would even go
to equality of outcome I might first
start on there's a lot of allegations
about equality of opportunity that
aren't really
I mean the school thing is an example
right in theory everyone has the
opportunity to go to these schools but
in practice they don't because the
schools cost money yeah right and and so
one there are two important points there
one is a conceptual point to be really
clear about which is that meritocracy is
not the same thing as equality of
opportunity so meritocracy is you
measure people based on their
accomplishments but if it turns out that
to accomplish something you need
practice training investment in your
talents and people get different amounts
of investment in their talents then when
you accurately measure people based on
their accomplishments you violate
equality of opportunity and so
meritocracy which was sold to America as
the handmaiden of equality of
opportunity has in fact become an
obstacle to equality of opportunity what
about on the other side of a meritocracy
and I think maybe at the beginning of
our conversation when you said that a
full meritocracy actually would would be
very bad in some ways you know when
people say hey if unemployment's too
high a lot of people will choose not to
work because they'd rather the
unemployment I don't worry about
something like that because the truth is
most people want to work and there's
value in doing things I like I just
don't worry about the free-rider problem
but it's certainly true that in a
distribution of humans there are people
whose accomplishments even when given
opportunities might not be that good and
I don't think they deserve to be left
behind and that seems to be a problem on
the other side of a true meritocracy so
this is a big problem and it's a problem
even in the idealized case that you
describe in a much bigger problem in our
actual case so even in the idealized
case what meritocracy says is that if
you don't succeed is your fault and so
it adds a kind of moral insult to the
economic and social injury of being left
behind and even when the meritocracy is
fair that's not a very humane way of
dealing with people hmm but when the
meritocracy on top of that is unfair and
you have a huge segment of the
population you know 70 80 percent of the
population that is structurally excluded
from advantage by all the ways in which
the rich out invest in their children
and then because
we pretend it's a meritocracy society
says to people who didn't get ahead it's
your fault that you didn't get ahead you
didn't measure up you know then you get
a sort of dark psychology of allegedly
justified disadvantage and that turns
people into racist populist it turns
people into forms of self-hatred and
self-destruction and and it accounts for
a large share I think of the social and
political dysfunction that we face in
our country today
so when I try to apply these issues that
you raised in the book to different
political systems I have a bias in that
I tend to go towards the ideas of
northern European social democracy as
pretty good for a lot of circumstances
and what I like about that framework
when we think about a meritocracy is
that there is opportunity for people to
do well and very very well but there are
mechanisms to sort of at the top put in
some safeguards that can be reallocated
to the bottom to make sure that there
are fewer or less severe losers from
meritocracy do you agree in terms of the
political systems in terms of social
democracy dealing with this or what
political solutions do you see I think I
share your politics I may be a little to
the left of that vision myself but um
it's important to me to distinguish my
own private political views from the
analysis of the book and I think an
outlook is very much in line with that I
think one thing I'd add to that is it's
important to separate what we might call
excellence from superior 30 so
excellence is being good enough at
something worth doing to make doing it
worthwhile superiority being better than
somebody else at something and one of
the other features of northern European
social democracy is they emphasize
excellence and de-emphasize superiority
so their banking system for example
finance in Germany is managed by a bunch
of trained up local bankers who are good
at delivering banking services but are
not super competitive desiring
superior to others at trading
complicated derivatives because that
turns out not to be very socially useful
and so you want to temper inequality
both through redistribution but also by
structuring your economy in such a way
that you create lots of opportunities
for people to do worthwhile jobs well
without worrying about whether they're
doing them better than the next guy
which may not actually be socially very
important yeah that's a that's an
important distinction that is totally
absent in the American finance system
anyway and probably in many others the
book is the meritocracy trap how
America's foundational myth feeds
inequality dismantles the middle class
and devours the elite we've been
speaking with the book's author Daniel
Markovitz a Daniel so appreciate your
time today I'm so full for yours it's
been a real pleasure speaking and so
listening so thanks very much